at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking facility this episode is brought
to you exclusively by LinkedIn marketing
solutions the go-to tool for b2b
marketers and advertisers who want to
drive brand awareness generate leads or
build long-term relationships that
result in real business impact could be
all of the above I've had Reid Hoffman
co-founder of LinkedIn on this podcast a
number of times often called the Oracle
of Silicon Valley for many different
reasons and he among other people and
friends of mine have made me more and
more interested in LinkedIn as a
platform as an ecosystem in the last few
years and it's it's very nuanced it's
very subtle but can be used in some very
powerful ways with a community of more
than five hundred and seventy five
million professionals LinkedIn is
gigantic but it can be hyper specific
you have access to a very diverse group
of people all searching for things they
need to grow professionally that is
explicitly the purpose of LinkedIn and
four out of five users on LinkedIn are
decision makers at their companies so
you can build relationships that really
matter that can drive your business
objectives forward that can also have a
high LTV lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective so why spray-and-pray
with your marketing dollars when you can
be surgical it just makes sense to
redeem a free $100 LinkedIn ad credit
and launch your first campaign go to
linkedin.com forward slash TFS that
stands for Tim Ferriss show
so that is linkedin.com forward slash
TFS check it out
that's where you can go to get your free
$100 ad credit LinkedIn comport /tf s
terms and conditions apply hello boys
and girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to sit down with world-class
performers of all different types to
tease out the habits routines favorite
books and so on that you can apply and
test in your own life this episode
features one of my favorite guests he
has been on before and he does not
disappoint
he somehow manages to think and speak
and finished prose Seth Godin on Twitter
you can find him at this is Seth's blog
and online is one of those popular blogs
in the world Seth's dot blog is his
website Seth is the author of 18
best-selling books that have been
translated into more than 35 languages
he was inducted into the direct
marketing Hall of Fame in 2013 very
rightly very well deserved I might add
and has founded several companies
including Yoyodyne and Squidoo his blog
which you can find by typing Seth into
Google is one of the most popular in the
world and he has I think 7,000 plus
posts at this point Seth writes about
marketing strategic quitting which we
get into in this episode leadership the
way ideas spread and challenging the
status quo in all areas and he really
walks the talk and does so in his
personal and professional life his books
include linchpin tribes the dip and
purple cow among others and Seth's
newest book is this is marketing
subtitle you can't be seen until you
learn to see you can find out more about
that at Seth's not blog forward slash
Tim in this case Tim doesn't stand for
my name it stands for this is marketing
where you can also find a free pdf
excerpt from the book as well as related
videos last but not least Seth is the
founder of alt MBA an intense four week
online leadership and management
workshop and you can learn more about
that at alt nba.com in this episode we
cover a lot I really encourage you to
listen to the whole thing and I brought
in questions from my own personal
challenges right now my own personal
goals also from friends and for many of
you who have voiced
certain patterns of challenges and
problems in hopes and desires so we talk
about among other things how Seth
personally deals with overwhelm and how
he thinks about it how Seth chooses
projects right alongside that how does
he say no to the unimportant and set
boundaries the difference between long
work and hard work the world's worst
boss which is very important portion of
the conversation how to find your
smallest viable audience hugely
important concept for all entrepreneurs
which pairs very well with 1,000 true
fans by kevin kelly which is an essay I
always recommend which you can find at
KK org non marketing books that are
master classes in great marketing and we
also somehow managed to get to what it
is like or how we think about crafting
April Fool's jokes that was not expected
and something that Seth brought up
himself
I hope you enjoy this episode as much as
I did I had an absolute blast and could
have gone for many many more hours so
without further ado please enjoy this
episode with the incredibly talented
polymath Seth Godin Seth welcome to the
show thank you Tim it's such a privilege
to be back I am thrilled to have yet
another opportunity to pick your brain
an expression that I loathe but
nonetheless seems appropriate in this
particular conversation and in every
conversation we've had many chats since
the last time we recorded but I thought
I would kick off with a topic that is
very top of mind for me and that is
overwhelm and we're gonna go all over
the place as is my want in this
conversation but overwhelm has come up
just today in multiple conversations
with friends and they range from people
who are at the top of their fields to
people who are trying to find an
inflection point for themselves
professionally to people who are
struggling in their early stages of
different projects and they all
mentioned to me that they felt
overwhelmed and even looking around me
right now my luggage from recent travel
seems to have exploded into miles of
paper and books
all around me on this table where I'm
sitting and I can't help but feel a
certain degree of maybe it is overwhelm
a what to do with all of this I'm not
sure where to even begin and I was I was
curious to know how you experience if
you do experience overwhelm because
there's part of me that all my recent
travels saw this documentary will you be
my neighbor about Fred Rogers mr. Rogers
sir Andy weir daffle it's a beautiful
movie and he weighed 143 for decades to
the pound every day and seemed to have
his life so cleanly dialed that only
towards the end did you see some of the
struggles he had but I wondered does
seth godin feel overwhelmed is that
something you experience how I've
definitely felt it and it's super
painful and I think one reason it's so
painful is because it comes with shame
yes it's a shame of well there are so
many people who don't have enough there
are so many people who have insufficient
choices insufficient inputs insufficient
leverage and Here I am feeling
overwhelmed underground deluged by this
thing that I asked for and the thing is
it's a systems problem because drinking
from a firehose is a really bad way to
get hydration yeah it's a dumb choice to
drink from a fire hose and so what I
have chosen to do to work my way out of
it is not let the world direct
boundaries for me but decide direct my
own boundaries so the example is you
know I remember the magical days when
once a month Wired magazine would show
up and Fast Company would show up and so
I knew that in three hours I could be as
informed as I needed to be just from two
periodicals and so the world was gating
the information that was coming in front
of me but now all of us are one click
away from all these people who are
talking about us behind our back from
political machinations that we need to
worry about from environmental
information and work-related stuff and
if we don't figure out
what's truly important to us then we
have this system breakdown because we
the the boundary we we used to rely on
is gone mmm-hmm are there other like
could you give any particular examples
of boundaries you've created or
situations of overwhelm that you've
found your way out of or resolved in
some way well the most useful thing I
can say and then people don't have to
listen to the rest of the podcast is if
you can figure out how to clear six
hours a day out for your life that's an
enormous ROI so I don't go to meetings I
don't watch television and I don't look
at Facebook or Twitter so if you got rid
of those four things how many hours a
day would be freed up and then you can
say to yourself alright but what did I
miss
and you can add back from a zero based
budgeting method which ones you're
missing but for me when if I am
challenged and forced to go to a meeting
and I look around that room and I'm
imagining that those people who are just
sitting there in real time absorbing
something that could have been
summarized in a four minute memo that
they do that three four five six times a
day well it's no wonder they feel
overwhelmed by the important work
because they've used up most of their
day on unimportant work and so that's
the first step and then the second thing
is when and I do feel overwhelmed when I
have fallen behind it could be that I
forgot to catch up with a piece of
software and suddenly there's a new
version that I need to learn and they're
they've changed the interface without
asking my permission right and so I know
that I need to be able to use the
software going forward and I'm trapped
because it's gonna take me a long time
to figure out the new Photoshop or a
long time to replace macromedia freehand
when they discontinued it and I'm not
happy about that but no one cares about
my opinion so at that point it's back to
emotional labor my labor is not digging
a ditch my labor is do I care enough to
experience
Comfort to get to the other side and if
I don't that I should turn off the input
because sitting with an uncomfortable
input when we don't care enough to make
things better is just a formula to be
unhappy I want to and this will seem
like a segue but I think it's it's
layering perhaps a different direction
on top of the same topic and this is you
may recognize this a piece titled the
world's worst boss and here's how it
reads the world's worst boss that would
be you even if you're not self-employed
your boss is you you manage your career
your day your responses you manage how
you sell your services in your education
and the way you talk to yourself odds
are you're doing it poorly if you had a
manager that talked to you the way you
talk to you you'd quit if you had a boss
that wasted as much of your time as you
do they'd fire her if an organization
developed its employees as poorly as you
are developing yourself it would soon go
under and there's a lot more to this and
then it closes with there are a few good
books on being a good manager if you
were still on managing yourself it's
hard to think of a more essential thing
to learn and the reason there are many
reasons I want to bring this up this is
from your blog and I think that's
December 2010 is that it seems to me
there are different species of overwhelm
some are from not managing inputs so you
just are getting shot in the face with a
fire hose and it may not even be water
you're just not choosing the material
nor the volume coming in there's feeling
behind and then there's also managing
yourself in so much as managing your
priorities and choosing what to do
knowing what to do how do you choose
your projects are there times when you
look at I would have to imagine there
are your well known guy even if even
before you were kind of Seth Godin in
marquee lights would have multiple
projects to which you could dedicate
your time and I think people very often
with that paradox of choice or feel
like there's gonna be a huge opportunity
cost no matter what they do end up
feeling overwhelmed or a high degree of
stress how have you navigated that
yourself
well first I'm so glad you brought this
post up I still remember the day I wrote
it and it was almost a mic drop moment
after I wrote that post I was very close
to turning off my blog just to say I got
nothing left that's that's it I guess
but instead we built the Alta MBA
because the Auld MBA is about that very
thing
which is these are mostly choices that
free people get to make when they don't
feel like free people that we feel like
we've made commitments or we are under
someone's thumb or it's not up to us but
in the medium run never mind the long
run it is up to us and how we make those
choices informs our days so I get
offered something to do and it feels in
the moment like it's an easy yes or no
question that the latest meme going
around in unsolicited emails is this
will take 45 seconds yeah right well it
will take 45 seconds to read it but if I
say yes then it will take me a year and
a half to get it done right so no it's
not a 45 second ask it's a year and a
half ass and what's happened as each of
us has become a freelance or a market or
a voice in social media or wherever we
are the number of places where you can
do work for free is close to infinity
and the number of places where you can
get paid a little to do work is large
and there are even some places where you
can get paid to do work and get more
than a little but the question is as the
CEO of you is that the commitment that
you want to make so I would say that
when I look back at the last twenty
eight years that I've been unemployed
the choices that I've made of saying yes
or saying you know are at the heart of
the career it's not the work as much as
it is deciding to do the work and
deciding what work not to do and I get
wrong often one way one way I get it
wrong is if someone offers me a speaking
gig and I look on my calendar and
there's no speaking gig for that whole
month I am way more likely to take it
than if there's two speaking gigs that
month that's a really bad way to do the
math really bad way and so I've gotten
better at being super selective at those
sorts of choices could you talk about
expand on why that's a bad way to make
the decision and what a better way is to
make the decision well it's that's a
choice made on a belief of insufficiency
that I feel in that moment like I will
never get asked to give a speaking gig
again because here's the evidence no
one's asked me to give a speaking gig
that month this must be the end and if
it's the end and you get to play one
more song on the guitar sure I'll play
one more song but I've been proven wrong
a thousand times a thousand times that I
thought I was never going to get another
speaking gig I've gotten another
speaking gig so I need to find this
efficiency the feeling of confidence of
enoughness to be able to say you know
what life is a series of short terms
that's what makes the long term but if
all you're doing is maximizing in the
short term you're going to break the
system because the system is not the
short term the system it's the life
you've chosen to live and you know one
of the the books I've been thinking
about a lot lately is a book called
stone age economics by Marshall Sahlins
and it made his career in the 1960s and
basically what he is an anthropologist
what he was able to show is that cavemen
didn't work very hard and our vision of
cavemen is that they were always
foraging that they were always hunting
that it was a frantic long and to think
law dramatic lifestyle but he says
actually about four hours a day and then
they could get back to the business of
living and what's happened for people
who are lucky enough to do what you and
I do who are lucky enough to listen to a
podcast like this because they have the
freedom to invest an hour to
getting better is we get greedy because
there's one more thing we could grab but
what we've discovered is if you grab too
many things you drop the whole basket
and then you got nothing could you talk
about the difference between and this is
coming back yet to the the well the font
of all good things your blog this is
from I believe in May of 2011 long work
versus hard work is that something that
you could describe for people the
difference between long work and hard
work well you know I think we've seen a
lot of people blog about this lately
and it's about how we make these
difficult choices right so if you're a
lawyer and you're building a lot of
hours if you are somebody who's making
it up in piecemeal then that's
exhausting whereas hard work is
different hard work is the emotional
labor of confronting risk the emotional
labor of finding generosity when you
don't feel like it
the emotional risk of seeing nuance
where there isn't a lot of nuance so if
we look at the platforms that are the
easiest to get on whether it's 5:00 or
medium or whatever they reward long work
the extra hour the hour after that the
hour after that because there's no curve
the twelfth hour does it get you more
than the first hour did it's just one
more hour whereas people who are willing
to do the hard work are the ones who are
toiling with no obvious applause who are
doing something that doesn't make the
crowd happy in the short run who are
confronting things that feel risky
because they understand that over time
they're not risky they're actually
generous and useful can you give any
real-life examples from your own
experience of choosing hard work
something that perhaps fuels risky or
seems risky to others or that is not a
crowd please
in the short-term are there any that
come to mind well I think just about all
the successes I can point to would match
that I would say first of all as a
speaker the first hundred speeches I
gave I paid money to give them and the
you know the first time I spoke in
Internet world I was the number 800th
ranked speaker on the list of speakers
that most people who would like the life
of someone who gives speeches would like
to start by getting invited to Davos or
right and you know you have to get booed
offstage a whole bunch of times or you
know when you think about the difficult
work of being in a new medium when you
started your podcast no one listened to
it when I started the alt n ba and these
other online things I do it was there
weren't a lot of people who were saying
exactly that's what we've been waiting
for and so you've got to be in the in
this cycle of making a mess in order to
slowly organize it into the thing that
over time will feel like the right thing
but there are two pots of gold at the
end of the rainbow one pot of gold is
you did something worth doing and the
other one is the extra hour at the end
of the day is no longer necessary
because you've built an asset you're no
longer on the clock right which you are
as someone who's creating value merely
by the thing you produced not because
someone's got to stop watching measuring
how many hours you're working right it's
the the decision that removes a hundred
later decisions or a thousand later
decisions perhaps in some capacity the
all-nba in those early days why did you
have the conviction to build that
specifically in just just so people have
a window into your thought process which
might help them find the courage to also
make some of these decisions to do hard
work as opposed to the long work and
there are some very very concrete
examples of friends were running into
trouble with this right now
in in my world but
what gave you the conviction why did you
have the confidence to persist when it
wasn't greeted with thunderous standing
ovations from the masses immediately
upon release or developing it okay so we
all have so many more degrees of freedom
so I have to begin by what am I not
going to actively pursue so I have an 18
page business plan right here for a
software company that I think could be
really successful and I've run software
companies I think I know how to do it
but I have to get back to first
principles and say have I decided to
dedicate the next cycle of my life to
running a company with lots of people
and the risks that go with that or do I
want to persist it being a teacher
because being a teacher is the arc I've
had for a long time and I get a lot of
satisfaction out of it so I've got to
start with that decision
so once I've made the decision I'm going
to be a teacher then I'm saying well I
know how to teach him one medium or
another medium but the world changes and
the forcing change agent here is what
happens when we can deliver education
via video so I played with online video
stuff and I saw what was working I saw
what wasn't and I wasn't thrilled at
what I could do in that medium alone so
putting those two things together I said
look if my mission is to teach people
and I'm not a consultant and I'm not a
coach what's my tool where I'm gonna
have the most impact on people and so I
literally went to the desert and I sat
there for a few days I went with friends
but I wasn't much good at company
because I I said this is a creative
moment for me and I'm gonna come back
from this trip and either say I have a
thing or I'm gonna say I'm walking away
from that in medium entirely because I
needed to make a leap and so I cornered
myself and I said you don't need more
time you just need to decide lay it out
what would it be if you had to do it so
by that acting as if I built a thing out
of paper that was you know
three-dimensional and you could
show it to people and I showed it to
people and at least half of them didn't
get it and I thought now I'm onto
something because if everyone said it
was a good idea it was probably by now
and so we we did a playtesting which is
an old software development term where I
pretended I was the system and people
engaged with me as the computer and it I
said yeah I'll put my name on this let's
see what happens and so the first time
we ran it I knew that the people who
would take it the only people who would
take it were people who give me the
benefit of the doubt which I've earned
by showing up and showing up but you
can't use the benefit of the doubt too
often because then you don't have it
anymore
so that was my risk my risk wasn't the
many hours we put into building it
because those were replaceable but the
trust that was serious and so the first
two or three days into it there was a
lot of nervousness because I'm not in
the alt NBA there's no videos of me I'm
not teaching it I just built a system
and about the fifth day some of the
people we had only 120 people in the
first session some of the people started
to reach out to me describing the shifts
that the projects were making in them
and in that moment I said ignoring sunk
costs knowing that canceling it at this
point had no cost to me he doesn't
matter how much time I spent building it
walk away if it's not good in that
moment I said I'm gonna stick with this
as long as we can keep making changes
like that happen and now it's 26
sessions later and each time we get more
confident that it works and each time we
get a different kind of person who shows
up because the people were showing up
now are the people who needed to wait to
see that it worked right three days in
the desert I can't just let that go in
passing what did you do in the desert
what was the format of those days for
you well the most important thing was
there was no internet and so going for a
walk it was a beautiful place of 65
degrees it was absolutely nothing too
and you bring a pad and you bring a
paper and as Neil Gaiman taught me the
best way to defeat my ders block is to
get really bored so that's what I tried
to do I got really bored I knew I had a
deadline no one else was waiting on me
for the deadline I'm my own boss but I
used that pressure that I invented for
myself to say there are things you are
afraid to write down there are things
you're afraid to assert but you have to
do it or else you can't keep talking
about this thing anymore how do you
train yourself to take self-imposed
deadlines seriously is it because you
have a cost and a trip with a start and
a finish in the form of this three-day
trip to the desert is it telling other
people you respect that you're going to
do this so that you have some shame if
you don't deliver or is it just a
conditioned response by doing it
repeatedly somehow but I I'd love to
know how you would explain that because
people miss deadlines all the time that
they set for themselves great question I
don't know many people with more
willpower than me I think you are one of
them I don't know how you do it but my
method is I only talk about the
deadlines I hit but I made it I made a
decision a very very long time ago
probably when I was 18 or 20 where I
said look there's a whole bunch of work
I'm just not willing to do I'm not
willing to be the person who takes good
notes I'm not willing to be the person
who memorizes I'm not willing to be the
person who can sit there for eight hours
doing what the boss says I'm just not
that person I don't that will kill me so
I got to do something else to be worth
something so here's what I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be the person who never misses
a deadline I'm gonna be the person who
has very strict rules about what I do
and what I don't do
and so you know I became a vegetarian
I haven't had chicken in I don't know 20
30 years and it doesn't even tempt me
and I've never done drugs doesn't even
tempt me because I made this this
once and so I'm really careful about
promising a deadline I'm really careful
about signing up for a project but once
I do the deal is done and I don't have
to revisit it and I get that people
wrestle with temptation all the time and
I'm not saying that the method I'm
describing is easy but I am saying when
we talk about bosses we admire when we
talk about business leaders or political
leaders who are States people and we
look to them with respect I think you
can look at yourself that same way if
you choose and a key part of it is to
say I'm not going to be situational
about my decision-making I'm going to be
strategic about my decision-making and
that choice you only have to make that
choice once and you're not gonna be
great at it at first but you can stop
acting like a 14 year old and start
acting like a grown-up and a
professional which means and this is
some place I've gotten in trouble before
authenticity is totally overrated
totally that I don't want an authentic
surgeon who says I don't really feel
like any surgery today I want a
professional whatever they feel like
right right
and so there are days that you will see
me give a talk or see me write or
something where I it is not my authentic
monkey brain saying whatever pops into
its head this is me playing the role of
Seth Godin being the professional who
does what he said he was going to do and
if that bothers people that I'm not
always authentic I'm sorry but at least
I'm consistent I love that I really do
yes yes is my way of agreeing with that
statement I've never heard it put quite
that way but I I really do not want an
orthopedic surgeon who decides halfway
through that he's it's really just not
his passion to finish my knee surgery
closely related to that is something
you've talked about it's so closely
related maybe it's just an inescapable
facet of all these things we're talking
about it would seem you
is this lizard brain and you've you've
written and spoken about the lizard
brain before in a want to say was an
interview Josh Kaufman you say that when
you hear quote the lizard brain the
scared voice what Steven Pressfield
calls the resistance and I think in
brackets here we have you do precisely
what it is afraid of it's basically it's
it's your compass but backwards and you
have very clear boundaries as you said
about what you do what you will do what
you will not do what would you say to
people who are afraid of saying no of
turning things down who know they don't
want to take a speaking engagement or
agree to some favor they're being asked
to perform but they they head they won't
say no or they'll hedge and say I'm not
sure ping me in a week even though they
know the answer should be no what would
you say to these people who may or may
not be named Tim Ferriss sometimes I
you're certainly not the poster child
for this and I know that you are a
scholar of no but let me let me break
this into a little bit first when I talk
about the lizard brain what I am
acknowledging is that the vast majority
maybe a hundred percent of what we
choose to do is done in the subconscious
and we make up the narrative afterwards
that that voice in our head is a press
secretary who's explaining to the media
without knowing exactly how why what we
just did was very smart and so if we can
acknowledge that then I can say to you
if you have not you Tim but you to
listener if you're having trouble with
this idea of overwhelm or the bounty or
saying no or focus it's not because
you're a defective human it might simply
be because you haven't trained for how
to deal with the chemicals that run
through your brain when you are
confronted with things having to do with
sufficiency insufficiency shame
fear fitting in standing out all of
these things flow through us like
lightning and all you have to do is go
to the movies to see that a director can
toy with us at any time they want
right they bring in some violin music
and all of a sudden were scared like no
one ever got hurt by a violin so why is
violin music in a movie scary it's
because we've been hardwired to believe
that just before the bad guy shows up
you know right well those things go
really deep into us it's Pavlovian I
don't know if that rings a bell or not
but the idea is sorry I was good the
idea is of course that's happening to
you it happens to all of us
great it happens to all of us now what
will you choose to do about it if you
want you can choose to be a professional
and so surgeons always wash their hands
even if they figured out they don't need
to today because there are no germs
she still washes her hands because you
always do because that's part of what it
is to be a surgeon so if your incoming
that's non-productive is that you say
yes to too many things you've got to
figure out what's the equivalent of the
hand-washing what's the equivalent of
the method that you're going to use to
go back to letting your cognitive
strategic brain have a say before you
get sucked in by the emotional reaction
or if it's difficult for you to say know
one thing that I find really helpful is
write four paragraphs that are
thoughtful generous and insightful about
why you're saying no copy it put it into
textexpander ampersand No so anytime
someone asks you this you can write
ampersand no and all four paragraphs
will come to that person it took you no
effort whatsoever they end up feeling
okay you end up feeling free and you can
get back to your job right and that half
is just a hack but it's the hack in the
service of why are you here what's the
change you are seeking to make
because we'd like to talk about the fact
that we are meaningful specifics a zig
Zigler would say that we are here to
make an impact but if you say those
things but then you act like a wandering
generality you're not gonna have the
impact you want for people who are not
aware textexpander is a software program
that allows you to type out something in
shorthand that then Auto populates
something else that's been predetermined
so that ampersand or the end symbol no
would then bring up the four paragraphs
that you have carefully crafted once to
be a polite decline it's a great program
yes and I was talking I was text
expanding my expect an explanation of
text expander what are some of your
equivalents of hand washing and just
just to to buy time or maybe just to
hear myself talk I'll share one that
came to mind when you said that which
was as a rule if if anyone tries to rush
me to make a decision very quickly the
answer is no so if if someone is trying
to use extreme time pressure to get me
to make a decision the answer is default
though which which has saved me more
times than it has in any way hindered me
and that that was I think a product of
necessity probably five years ago
particularly in the the cortisol driven
world of startups and and we're closing
around and forty-seven minutes right
maybe we can squeeze you in for forty
seven dollars are you in no your legal
doesn't have time to review documents
that type of stuff what what are some of
the any examples that come to mind yours
or from other people of the the
hand-washing well I'll give you two
edges one is think I decided what I was
going to do for a living and I decided
what I was willing to do for free huh so
if you want me to give a speech you have
to pay me on the other hand if you want
to read my blog post it's for
mmm-hmm if you show up and ask me to
endorse your sports team I will say no
but if you ask me to blurb your book I
will consider it because for free
because it's done been done for me and I
appreciate it if I can find a worthwhile
book I'm happy to put my voice behind it
but if you want me to endorse your
singing career no I don't do that sorry
and so being clear about where the free
stuff is and where the expensive stuff
is eliminates 80% of the people who are
hoping to have some sort of transaction
with me because I get it that it would
be really fun to come to your conference
in Wisconsin I understand that a
vacation in Wisconsin would be really
fun and here's my problem with that
number one I would have to every day
think about where I want to go on
vacation next and number two is I
couldn't be fair to people who had hired
me to give a speech because why do some
speeches go for free and some speeches
not so by being clear about that the
person in Wisconsin who has a great
conference and I'm sorry I can't come I
don't have to negotiate with them
because there's a price list and
interesting aside price tags were only
invented 120 years ago and we needed
them because we couldn't trust sales
clerks to haggle that before that the
owner and the sales clerk were the same
person and haggling makes gives me no
pleasure some people like to haggle I
hate to haggle and so I don't haggle I
want to come back to book blurbs here in
in a second this is a perfect example I
think to to explore some meta questions
and before I get there I want to say
that as it relates to speaking
engagements specifically speaking I
don't really do speaking anymore
it was sort of categorically one of the
things I decided I did not want to apply
much bandwidth to even though there are
times when I enjoy it but part of the
reason I found it so stressful is and I
think you gave me some very good advice
actually very very early on many many
years ago
as it related to speaking because you're
such a pro in that arena is that every
speaking engagement was a will a one-off
case-by-case negotiation and
consideration which doesn't drained
every calorie of decision-making out of
my brain each time took place and you
have some really fascinating ways we
don't we don't necessarily have to get
into if you don't want to about how you
choose what to do or price what to do a
friend of mine Josh Waitzkin gave me
great advice many years ago which was
and he'd he does I don't think really
any speaking anymore either but he was
the basis for searching for Bobby
Fischer some people might think of a
chess prodigy brilliant guy and he told
me at one point that long ago he decided
free or full price and what he meant by
that was only he only did two types of
speaking free four causes he felt
worthwhile and absolute full price and
no negotiation no 20% discount no will
do it for half price because of XY and Z
and I took that and implemented it as
every time a company paid me a price
that was a new high price for me they
set a new high watermark and that became
the new standard price so it was free or
whatever the highest price had been to
date and it worked really really well
was incredible how distressing that was
but book blurbs you mentioned as it
related to speaking engagements that you
wanted to be fair or feel that it was
fair so you weren't picking and choosing
so I have categorically decided I don't
do moderation very well with which often
leads I think in my mind to this one off
decision-making I'd like to make the one
decision that removes 100 decisions so
the book blurbs I just decided I have so
many friends asked me for book clubs
that I do not want to I don't even want
to consider the social cost of having to
pick among them for poplar so I don't do
any how do you handle that
you must get sent
a mountain of books or at least get
emails from people you know who are
authors asking for book clubs how do you
how do you vet them and how do you
gently let down people alright so let me
go to the first part first and then
we'll come back to book blurbs because I
think we can broaden this to anyone
who's a freelancer perfect
okay so freelancers have a long work
problem which is that if you do work
where I can find a substitute the only
way to move up is to work more hours and
that sucks because it ends up being a
race to the bottom and you're then
you're on Fiverr bidding you know $10
for a day's labor but some freelancers
do great why do those freelancers do
great number one they have better
clients better clients challenges you to
do better work better clients do take
you're better work and run with it
better clients put you in front of
better work and so if you're frustrated
as a freelancer begin by getting better
clients and the way you get better
clients is by turning down lesser
clients so that you're freed up enough
to do the hard work necessary to be
appealing to a better client if you have
a lousy client fire them even if it
means you'll be doing nothing so that
you can go back to looking for better
clients but then the other thing it's
really important to understand and it's
not just businesses it's human beings in
their daily life as well price is a
story it is not an absolute number so a
Tiffany's ring $6,000 if you buy it
brand new walk six blocks down to the
diamond district and 7th Avenue in New
York you can sell that brand new
Tiffany's ring that you paid $6,000 for
for a thousand dollars
what where'd the other money go right
it's not used where the other money went
is the person who bought it at tiffany's
was paying for the privilege of buying
it at Tiffany's and so when I think
about the the market for in this case
speaking there are tons of people who
can give a very good speech but they are
not famous
and as a result the person who hires
them cannot go to the people who they
work with and say great news we hired
Jimmy Bluestein because they would say
who's Jimmy Bluestein so what's actually
happening when they hire you to give a
speech is they are hiring the story of
they had enough money to pay Tim Ferriss
his current high price to get Tim
Ferriss to come on a plane and be in the
room and there's a lot of value in
selling that product because it's a
signaling strategy and it's worthwhile
so if you're Milton Glaser and you want
and someone wants Milton Glaser to make
their logo for them Milton would say
it's $250,000 and you say that's crazy I
can hire some kid on Fiverr for $12 and
you might even get the same logo but
what you wouldn't get is the ability to
say to the Board of Directors
we got Milton Glaser to make the logo so
though the hard work here of building a
career as a freelancer where you're
gonna get paid fairly is having the
willing doing the hard work to get
better clients and then having the guts
to turn down people who don't value your
reputation when they want to hire you so
that's my rant about pricing and in
terms of well I'll leave that part aside
and then in terms of blurbing here's
what happened I do I have evidence to
show that in almost every case blurbs do
not sell books and so why do authors
even want blurbs and here's what
happened to me when I was shifting from
being a book packager where I did 120
books in ten years with a small team
almanacs and things like that to being
an author I sent a book called get what
you deserve which I wrote and Jay
Levinson was my co-author - Tom Peters
and I had met Tom a couple times through
the years but we weren't partners or
golf buddies and Tom sent me back a
blurb and that blurb changed my life
because I started walking through the
world as the kind of person that could
have written a book that Tom Peters
liked
and Tom's point of view is is this book
worth more than $30 because if someone's
going to pay 15 for it and I think it's
worth more than 30 Wow
what a great thing I've done for the
reader by pointing out a book that's
worth more than it costs I'm not saying
it's the best book ever written I'm just
saying this book's probably worth your
time so for me I've made a bunch of
rules the first one which I have to live
with though I'm not crazy about is if
you don't have a publisher I'm not gonna
blurb your book and the reason is
because otherwise I'd have to deal with
infinity and if a publisher is getting
behind a book the value of my blurb to
you and your career is worth more
because now your editor who's under the
delusion that blurbs work with will
support your book more and thus it will
work right right and the second thing is
if you send me a note that is makes it
clear you're a favored trading scammer
then like here I pre wrote the blurb for
you you don't even need to read the book
I'm not gonna blurb your book because
that's disrespectful I read everything
that I blurb and most of the time I have
to say I don't have time to read your
book and I mean it but if I have time to
read your book I will either find things
in it that are worth the time and energy
you're asking the reader to put into it
or I will tell you that I got very busy
I will not send you a note explaining
why your book is no good because I've
tried that even with people I care about
it's a bad plan I
what is the wording for I got really
busy look like if you remember I do
remember it's I got really busy I'm very
sorry that that's it okay I mean here's
here's the deal first of all it's true
right I am really busy and this wasn't
didn't rise to the level of I couldn't
need to put even more time into this to
be able to dig something out for you but
the other thing is that more words don't
make the person feel better people want
to be
but they don't want to be snow balled
right they don't want a blizzard to come
at them they just want to know you
understand this isn't good news for them
you're sorry that you don't have good
news for them let's move on because it
doesn't pay for anybody for me to go on
and on and on because if I'm really busy
I don't have time to go on and on and on
and I am sorry I'm too busy to read your
book but here are three pages on why I'm
too busy to read your book so the the
topic of work directive of choosing
better clients is the part and parcel of
thinking clearly and you are very very
good at I think thinking and
communicating you're thinking clearly
and in well for first of all you you
have a new book which would have been
mentioned in the intro already but I'd
like you to very briefly tell me about
it
and therefore listeners about it but the
clarity of such purpose and thinking is
reflected I think very well in a
discussion you have in the book about
the quarter-inch drill bit and I'm not
not sure if whenever I read books
sometimes it's like I write my book my
books tend to be disturbingly
unnecessarily long so I'm like oh Jesus
did I write that what was that thing
that I wrote about hope I can recall it
but perhaps you could tell us a little
bit about the new book why you wrote it
and then the quarter-inch drill bit
well Ted Levitt was the godfather of
marketing in the early 1960s he wrote a
paper called marketing myopia that
changed the game for a lot of people and
in that paper and Harvard Business
Review he wrote no one buys a quarter
inch drill bit because they need a
quarter inch drill bit what they need is
quarter inch hole that's what you should
sell them in this book which is called
this is marketing in which I'm hoping
will be a seminal dividing line in how
we view where we are as that paper was I
point out no one needs a quarter inch
hole what would you possibly need to
quarter-inch hole for what you need is a
place to put the lag the expansion bolt
so you can put a screw in the wall but
actually don't need that what you need
is to put the shelf on the wall but you
don't really need that what you need is
a place to put the books that are
cluttering your bedroom but you don't
really even need that what you need is
the way you will feel when your spouse
thanks you for cleaning things up what
you really need is safety and security
and a feeling that you did something
that was important that's what we sell
and it turns out that's what we sell
when we sell everything and the thesis
of this is marketing is that there's
been four revolutions in memory the
Industrial Revolution of oh we can make
stuff right and the stuff we've been
making keeps getting better and better
the second one was this revolution that
computers can calculate things really
well which puts a man on the moon or
enables a robot to help build a car the
third one is computers as databases
moving information from far away to here
and from here to far away the connection
economy but this last one is the one
that every one of us gets to touch and
it's the revolution of marketing which
is that now each one of us has more
power than Procter & Gamble did 50 years
ago each one of us with a keyboard is
connected to more than a billion people
and my thesis is that we're responsible
for what we do with that power and that
if we want to we can do work that
matters for people who care that we can
make things better by making better
things and the people who regularly read
my work will recognize this but I needed
to put it in a book so they could share
it with their team they could share it
with the people around them because I
think if we catch our breath right now
we won't have to have this race to the
bottom of privacy prying spammy every
page on the web this looks a little bit
like a porn page because we've tested it
to death and maybe instead we can go in
the other direction and say
there's a group of people who need me
who need my voice who need the change I
want to make if I can find that group
the smallest viable audience and delight
them they will engage with me and they
will tell the others and this none of
this isn't Kotler none of this is in
marketing 1970-1980 none of it so we are
swimming in this water but we don't see
the water and I wanted to be able to put
a stake in the ground and say here you
go I've been doing this for 30 years
this is what I see and if you're working
on things I care about I hope you will
read this because this is my best shot
at helping you do better so to help
people do better I want to pull out
three words that you just mentioned
because you and I have chatted about
this not sure ever publicly but the
smallest viable audience can you excuse
NY it's important if this isn't your
first Tim Ferriss podcast you are fan of
Tim and the way he engages with the
world and yet 99% of the people on
planet earth have never heard of Tim
Ferriss to have him bought any of his
books they haven't listened to a word
he's ever spoken so here's somebody
who's successful beyond our wildest
dreams who is unknown to 99% of the
planet how can those two things coexist
well the answer is that the mainstream
media has pushed us to fit in to be
average to reach the masses because
masses and average are the same thing
but everyone's trying to do that there's
only room for one Kardashian right
everyone else is sort of 80% down the
list but if you can find the guts to say
there are 250 people who care about
tilt-shift
lenses as much as I do and I'm gonna
make a tilt shift lens for those 250
people that changes their life they will
find you because that's their Drive
that's their mission and so the
attention economy basically teaches us
that you are not in charge of what Pia
look at they are and if you go where
they are looking you will do way better
than if you insist that people look at
you how does one begin to pull back from
the the drive the temptation to make
everyone their customer and define who
their smallest viable audience might be
if if someone is currently let's just
take this may not be the best example so
feel free to come up with a better
example but let's say someone is
creating a YouTube channel they've been
doing it for a while it hasn't quite
clicked they're not sure what they're
doing wrong but they're trying to appeal
to moms or they're trying to appeal to
men between the ages of 20 and 30 I've
this could be a terrible terrible
example but how would you suggest
someone start to niche down are there
questions they should ask themselves any
particular resources or otherwise that
you would suggest oh it's a great
example here's the thing it's not your
problem isn't greed your problem isn't
that you are trying for more and more
and more your problem is fear the fear
of someone saying you're not as good as
you say you are and the fear of once
you've narrowed it down to the 500
people to be rejected by those people is
really hurtful because there's no one
left that's all there is and a living
with that fear is the hard work of the
professional so that the way we nice it
down is by committing to wanting to
Nisha town to not have false niches that
are actually just excuses for reaching
everyone but to be really really
specific so if I think about I don't
know a sushi place in New York City most
of the sushi places in New York City are
sushi places they're just there and
Astaire interchangeable but if you were
required to have a sushi place that
could pay the rent only being open 12
hours a week
or if the limit was we're gonna charge
$400 a meal now by default you've
eliminated almost anyone who would want
to engage with you the only people who
are left are the people who want
something that is not available in a
traditional sushi bar you've gone to an
edge and it's not an edge based on
demographics on gender or age or income
it's an edge based on psychographics and
what does this person dream of which
requires empathy and empathy is the
other part that makes us difficult
because here's the thing people don't
know what you know they don't want what
you want they don't believe what you
believe and yet you want to serve them
so what you have to do is acknowledge
that they are right they are right in
wanting what they want they are right in
needing what they need and maybe you can
earn their enrollment and teach them a
new way to be but you can't succeed by
insisting that people are you because
they're not there are there any highly
highly highly niche companies businesses
could be small could be not so small
that you are particularly fond of any
that any that come to mind well in the
book I talked about penguin magic so
that's an easy example penguin magic
almost no one listening to this is ever
bought anything from them and yet
they're a multi-million dollar company
magicians professional magicians don't
need any more magic tricks because they
do the same 12 tricks every night
different audience same 12 tricks
amateur magicians on the other hand have
the same audience all the time the
long-suffering family members and
co-workers watch this trick again and
again and so you need new tricks all the
time so that's what penguin did is they
said what would be the perfect website
for someone who's exactly that person
and that's what they built and there are
a hundred little details if you visit
penguin magic that you'll see
that probably aren't interesting to you
the outsider but to someone who's like
this this is what they dream of and by
obsessing about that niche and ignoring
everyone else they have managed to
succeed or an example totally the other
end of the spectrum I'm talking to you
in Scott Harrison's office at charity
water charity water has raised a quarter
of a billion dollars to bring water to
people who don't have clean water and
most philanthropists don't give them
money and most foundations don't give
them money and most individuals don't
give them money and that's fine because
for the people who wanted this kind of
interaction it's exactly what they
wanted so you have to shun the
non-believers and say yes you want to
give money the American Cancer Society
please do that's not what we do we do
this and this i this statement we do
this and being clear about what this is
and why is totally different then the
freelancer who says what do you need
because what do you need works great if
you're the local handyman but it stops
working great if suddenly there are a
thousand local handyman and everyone's a
click away
charity waters a really good example I'm
familiar charity water spent time with
Scott and they did a number and do thing
do a number of things very differently
they were I suppose even more remarkable
in the very beginning because at that
point then many others hadn't started
emulating them but very design driven
aesthetic driven nonprofit in a sense
their collateral their approach to web
design to experience design with events
is very much targeted to a particular
psychographic sort of the the MacBook
crowd for lack of a better description
and they also made they distinguished
themselves among other ways by
separating out the administer
of costs and covering the team
administrative costs of the nonprofit
from the building of actual wells and so
on which very few people had seen done
before even though they weren't the
first to do it since I'm glad that you
brought them up and that you also
brought up constraints like you
mentioned with this hypothetical sushi
restaurant that applies constraints to
arrive at a smallest viable audience
could you talk to if possible and you
can take this any way you want or
anywhere you want the the importance of
smallest viable audience as it relates
to charging enough or charging more
because I know so many entrepreneurs or
know of so many entrepreneurs who are
really gifted doing things well and yet
they just refuse to charge more than the
bare minimum because they want everyone
to be able to afford their product as
one example there are many reasons they
might cite but I would love to hear your
thoughts on charging enough or charging
more charging fill-in-the-blank this
this I see this as one of the most
common fatal errors or at least on a
company or project basis fatal errors
that entrepreneurs make is simply
pricing incorrectly long question but
very very much talk about yeah okay so
let's begin here if you sell rent
housing to low income people
if you sell healthcare to the masses
please please lower your price for
everybody else
this idea that people can't afford it
his crazy talk because let's look at dog
food the price of dog food has gone just
in the last 10 years from two or three
dollars a pound which is the stuff at
the supermarket to $45 a pound
which is the keto dog food that I bought
on a lark for my dog the other day now I
get that a grown up adult might be
hooked on this whole keto thinking but
as far as I can tell even though the
price of dog food has gone up by a
factor of 20 dogs are not any happier
than they used to be so it's not that
you're trying to make the dog happy
you're trying to make the dog owner
happy and the dog owner is happier
spending more money not all dog owners
just the dog owners who are happier by
spending more money that's who the
product is for and so what we think
about when we are not building a public
utility when we are an entrepreneur
who's going to the marketplace with an
innovation is we need to please a small
group of people and one of the signals
that is available to us his price and
the signal says if you are looking for
the lowest price and everything that
comes with that we are not those people
on the other hand if you're looking for
a fair price and everything that comes
with that the customer service the
attention to detail the fit and finish
the voluntary constraints where that so
take four letters into DuckDuckGo or
Google and om a just four letters and
Noma fills the screen right where did
Noma come from well if you want to open
the world's most famous new restaurant
Copenhagen is not a smart place to do it
and making the rule that you're only
going to serve food that you harvested
from within a hundred kilometers not
very smart either particularly if you
need to charge hundreds and hundreds of
dollars to do so but they voluntarily
accepted all of those constraints
knowing that they only needed to blow
the socks off ten thousand people that
if ten thousand people walked away from
that experience thrilled to pieces then
they would become famous to the family
they would become noteworthy enough that
people would fly there to engage with
them if they had open Noma
and said it's $18 so that forgives us
for cutting this quarter in this corner
in this corner in this corner you never
would have heard of Noma it's true yeah
and I would this is just to put in
perspective for people it's it's not
just the price of the meal you have to
consider that almost everyone who's
going to Nome is flying in
internationally right so these meals end
up costing five ten thousand dollars
when you factor in all of the all the
indirect and direct costs and yet as you
pointed out or maybe not end yet and
because in part because of that Noma is
what it is which is one of if not the
most famous restaurant in the world much
like El Bulli back in the day yeah or
conceal or consider a movie like 2001 a
Space Odyssey right considered by
everyone to be one of the 50 greatest
movies ever made almost every single
critic pandit that the first 45 minutes
of the movie 45 minutes no words are
spoken the first minute of the movie the
screen is black that there's nothing
about that movie that was designed to
please the crowd that's not who he made
it for and that's how he ended up with a
movie that people still watch 50 years
later what is the three sentence
marketing promise template whereas the I
guess it's a simple marketing promise
and I can certainly read this if you
would like if it makes it a little
easier but there's a template that you
have three sentence marketing promise
you can run with and if you can pull it
from memory we can do that or I can
bring it up and we can explore each of
these in turn do you have friends tell
me if I got it right it's for people who
believe this and for people who want
that this might be what you're looking
for so close to that it is close yeah my
product is for people who believe blank
I'll focus on people who want blank I
promise it engaging with what I make
will help you get
blank but I think both what you laid out
and that are very very similar in intent
what what is this why is it my is it
important well what tends to happen is
companies make a thing then they hand
that thing to the marketing department
and the marketing department reverse
engineers what they're gonna say about
it to get people to buy it and then they
come up with a mealy-mouthed mission
statement it says nothing so that they
can act universally so whenever the new
next new product comes in it they won't
have to change their mission statement
none of this is effective the
alternative is to say we're not saying
we made this please come by it we're
saying we see you we see who you are and
what you believe and we are search right
here right now we assert that if you're
the kind of person that believes this
and is looking for this we promise that
if you engage with your time and money
with us you will get that and if you can
articulate that arc then you've got a
shot at engaging with this smallest
viable audience so when I think about
you know we've been talking about
marketing for over now we haven't
mentioned Apple once when I think about
what DS Apple promised when you pay
extra for a smartphone that is
demonstrably not better than the
alternative that another company makes
how do they get you to wait in line well
what they're saying is for people who in
some small way define their status among
their peers by the device that they use
who will get pleasure out of being able
to demonstrate to their peers that they
have the resources to get the latest one
we have the latest one get in line if
you want one that is Tim Cook's entire
business model that's not what Steve
Jobs business model was but that's Tim
Cook's one which is they're selling a
luxury good
which raises the status of insiders and
is of no interest whatsoever to people
who don't get the joke are there any
other companies that come to mind that
do a particularly good job of this or
any poor any and by company that could
be one person could be $10 I will I will
stake my reputation by telling you that
every successful company does this they
don't do it on purpose necessarily but
the thing that made them successful is
that they did this that there is almost
nothing that launched to the masses so I
remember the first time I used uber and
I did not use uber because I had no
other way in New York City to get 20
blocks across town I used uber because
I'm the kind of person that got pleasure
out of taking a magical electronic
device out of my pocket pressing a
button and having my friends just a GOG
at the fact that a minute later a
vehicle showed up right where we were
standing
that that feeling is what I bought when
I bought Ober so that at the beginning
Hoover had almost no customers but the
customers they had were people who liked
that feeling and it then it works its
way through a curve which we can talk
about it later if you want but at the
beginning that's what we saw at Amazon
that's what we saw at Airbnb if we're
talking about offline businesses right
that's what you see at a certain kind of
hairdresser that's what you see at a
certain kind of fashion label that
there's a line out front of supreme
where people are buying a t-shirt that
cost $3 to make for $45 why are they
waiting in line what do they get who
wants a supreme t-shirt those questions
aren't things you do after you decide to
be in the t-shirt business you go the
other way you figure out what are the
needs and the dreams and the desires
that are people are walking around with
unfulfilled and you say hi I'm here to
help you achieve what you already wanted
do you have any idea what supreme is
doing well why are people waiting in
line to buy a $3 t-shirt for $45 if you
if even if even if you just had to guess
is there any Sony stem you take we need
to talk about the yo-yo Union for a
minute let's do it
so yo-yos are regularly band or frowned
upon in elementary schools because of
what happened last time but every once
in a while three wait what happened last
I'm gonna get to that
so okay everything every three or four
years a kid shows up with a yo-yo and if
that kid is a low status kid that's the
end of it
but if that kid who shows up is one that
other kids want to be near and like not
all kids just certain other kids the
next day there are three yo-yos and then
there are seven yo-yos and then there
are 50 yo-yos and within a week and a
half
yo-yos are everywhere and then yo-yos
get out of hand so the administration
passes a rule no more yo-yos and it
takes three more years for it to come
back again like the locusts exactly
laughing and so I've seen this happen
first hand I've seen it when it worked
and I seen it when it didn't work and so
the secret is to make sure the right kid
brings the yo-yo to school the first day
because if it's not the right kid the
status roles aren't at work and you
don't get the yo-yo to spread so
Supremes homerun
was that a certain kind of kid with a
certain kind of status showed off his
parents money by showing up with a
t-shirt that was intentionally a
aggressively obnoxiously designed and be
ridiculously expensive because that
moment of how ridiculous it was created
all the value now if the wrong kid had
shown up wearing a supreme t-shirt
nothing but the right kid did and so
other kids wanted it and in this moment
supreme made a really smart choice which
is they under produced dramatically
they always sold out they left money on
the table this is the hard work part
again they left it on the table and left
it on the table they left it on the
table they could have sold way more but
they believed that they would be doing
this for years and so they intentionally
created this scarcity and scarcity
creates a feeling of value and so now I
was just researching this a couple weeks
ago down there most of the people who
are waiting in line are gonna resell it
within ten minutes that though they need
the line to show up in photographs so
that the person who buys it at a premium
is relieved at how well often smart
they're that they didn't have to wait in
line so the line is a tax that creates
value for the people in the marketplace
this cannot go on forever it never does
but to create a fashion brand that is
based on nothing but scarcity that's the
method it's a story that makes me think
of something right here in my backyard
in Austin Texas which is Franklin's
barbecue and most people have never
heard of Franklin's barbecue nonetheless
I want to say they open at 10:00 a.m.
something along those lines and they
sell out by 11:00 a.m. everything that
they have made all of the meat they have
prepared and that's the end of the day
they close when they sell out could they
produce more of course they could
produce more and people start lining up
around 6:00 a.m. there are cottage
industries coffee shops and so on
that have developed to capitalize on
this line and early on it was predicted
that this might last three months six
months a year it's been going on for I
want to say at least five or six years
sure this line and the food is
exceptional but there is exceptional
barbecue all over Texas and it is this
incredible ludicrous on some levels
scarcity that becomes the PR campaign in
a way right so Dory's some people tell
about example
the TaskRabbit they hire to stand in
line or whatever it might be so there
becomes this narrative to things that
need to be understood here the first one
is in a double blind taste-test
they would never win but that's okay cuz
we're not double blind no one is double
blind we know where it came from and so
if you know where it came from it might
win because what you're actually tasting
is what it took to get it and there's
nothing wrong with that and this is
another key part because you are not
manipulating people you are serving them
they are choosing to go through these
steps because those steps make the
barbecue taste better it's a placebo and
placebos are wonderful because they
don't have any side effects and because
they actually work so we can be honest
ethical generous marketers by saying my
job is to put on the show
I'm not simply a manufacturer someone
can always manufacture cheaper than me
but people will pay for our trust and
experience something to talk about
scarcity and the way it feels to be part
of something that's what we build and so
what we have to figure out how to do is
build it in a way that when people find
out that's what we're doing they're
still okay with it
I love how encyclopedic your knowledge
is of case studies it's it's really one
of the for me at least one of the things
that immediately leaps to mind as a
distinguishing characteristic of a lot
of your work is pulling in and
dissecting in a way or at least
observing case studies are there any
other examples that come to mind where
you think this is pretty been discussing
is done particularly well well now that
you've said that of course there's you
know I think that when we think about
the work of contemporary art it's really
you
to see that people who don't get the
joke completely don't get the joke right
they say oh I could have painted that
painting that Jackson Pollock painted it
how could it be worth forty five million
dollars but Jackson Pollock had a
brother and his brother's name was
Charles and Charles Pollock was a
painter not an artist Charles Pollock
painted exactly like his teacher Thomas
Hart Benton but we didn't need another
painter to paint like Thomas Hart Benton
because we already had one so the act
number one that Jackson Pollock painted
something no one else was painting that
many people hated number two that he had
gallery representation in New York City
that enabled the gallery owner to say
for the kind of collector that wants to
earn the status with a certain set
appears that comes from owning a
painting that no one else owns this is
the kind of artist that you might like
that's how you get your start and then
the next step in the path is there are
curators who understand that their
career will be advanced if they are one
of the early ones to hang this on the
wall of their museum there are other
curators who understand that their
career will be advanced if they're one
in the middle or late ones who hang it
up and so this virtuous cycle is created
and you go from you could have bought
the painting for $1,000 to now it's
worth 45 million and it is worth 45
million not because you can't see it for
free of course you can on Google it's
that the act of owning it
earns you a certain kind of status in
your own head and with a certain circle
of people that's worth something but
right down the street there's a guy who
collects guitars he doesn't want a
Jackson Pollock he wants a signed you
know Eric Clapton guitar and different
people are making these decisions based
on where they think it puts them in the
pecking order of who eats first and who
has better taste and who's an insider
and who's an outsider and because we
live in such a privileged world
that's what people are spending all
their time paying attention to I am so
glad that you brought up Jackson Pollock
I've a bunch of history with Jackson
Pollock that you and I talk about some
how you grew up down the street I did I
did indeed and in fact there's a grocery
store
before Jackson Pollock became Jackson
Pollock in all caps there's a grocery
store where he used to trade his
paintings for her head and eggs
and so on before he's in some respects I
suppose crack the code and I recently
found a book and there are there
portions of it that are good I think a
lot of it is is about what you would
expect which is a lot of hyperbole and
high-concept confusion but 100 secrets
of the art world I've become fascinated
by the weirdness but also on some levels
the the impeccable logic of how the art
world works there's a lot of weirdness
there certainly aspects I don't yet
understand but I found this at a really
cool festival that people may be
interested in called the trans-pecos I
think it's music festival but it may
just be the trans-pecos PE cos in Marfa
Texas which the story of Marfa Texas in
an unselfie yeah is a kind of a crazy
marketing story in in some respects
people can check it out it's in the
middle of nowhere and found this book
and here's a quote from Jeff Koons who's
also from my native New York artist and
sculptor and this elitist this'll lead
us back to marketing as many things do
here's the quote it's one of my
favorites so the quote the journey of
art starts with self-acceptance the
subjective
once you accept yourself you were able
to move on to the objective the highest
state which is the acceptance of others
and I found that worth pondering oh
that's beautiful which which leads me to
a note that I took from your new book
which is a chapter titled marketing to
the most important person and I was I
was wondering and I took some additional
notes on that chapter or at least a few
lines but
who's the most important person what is
marketing for the most important person
oh it's you
right it's a we have so if we're in a
post-industrial place where you're not
spending all day working the punch press
the person we spend most like where we
started the world's worst boss right in
this case what we're talking about is
who are you talking to when you talk to
yourself about what you do and how do
you come to grips with this self
acceptance that Jeff Koons is talking
about and I love that you're bringing
these pieces together because that's
exactly the way I'm thinking about it
this all started with what I saw
happening inside the old MBA where
people with talent when they felt safe
were very clear that they didn't believe
in who they were where they were going
or what they were creating and until
they could come to grips with the fact
that they had value to add it's really
difficult to have the sufficiency to
have empathy to have the sufficiency to
see other people because if you're
drowning you're a lousy lifeguard yes as
well said how does someone develop the
feeling of sufficiency so that they are
if not on land at least swimming
comfortably as a lifeguard so they can
have the empathy for others that's
necessary to be good then marketing the
gifts they have what they can provide
how does how does one develop that self
compassion and that feeling of
sufficiency here's my best take on it as
soon as you can adopt the posture that
you are needed to do a generous act that
someone in worse shape than you is
drowning and that you have something to
offer them it shifts from a selfish act
that is shameful to a generous act that
is making a difference so it requires us
not to be selfish
this is not double-talk but that once we
realize that there actually is somebody
who would miss us if we were gone then
we can get out of our head and realize
we are not doing this to get in the
light or to hide from the light we are
doing this because someone else needs us
and so the big shift is to stop thinking
of prospects stop thinking about people
you are marketing to or at and instead
say where are my students where are the
people who are enrolled in this journey
who I have a chance to teach because if
I'm a teacher and the student is coming
along for the ride I don't have to yell
I don't have to interrupt and I have to
hit kids with a ruler all I need to do
is take them to where they said they
wanted to go and that fits into the
person I think most of us would like to
be which is the teacher we would
remember years later the person who
turned on a light for someone who didn't
have a light Seth I aspire to be half
the communicator you are I am just
constantly astonished how clear you were
able to convey the thinking which of
course in the first place
must be clear to you before you can
impart it to others does those very
beautifully said and I think very very
important so thank you well for that
that means the world to me and I just
want to insert here not that we're
playing tennis but the single best
written April Fool's joke in the history
of the internet was written by you and
there's a sort of elegance that's
necessary that isn't in my wheelhouse
that enables somebody to have enough
awareness of the narrative of the reader
and enough guts to go right to the edge
but not go over to do it in that
indirect form and that's not my milieu
it's yours but it was beautiful
inside what
well it's been a while it's been a long
time since since since I did that so
would you mind if you if you want to
take a stab at I can also take a stab at
it but do you want to take a stab at
describing what that April Fool's
joshua's well so here's the I have now
resigned from my annual April Fool's
blog post because when it works people
send me angry notes and when it doesn't
work people send me I wasn't getting
anything out of it but there was a
tradition that if you are a blogger on
April Fool's Day you had to come up with
something using just words that would
not only get under people's skin and
Surprise them but make your point and
your blog post if I remember it and it
was 10 years ago whatever eight years
ago was I have a confession to make I
don't write this blog I've out sourced
it as part of my 4-hour work week agenda
and this blog is actually written by
someone else
oh it's right it has been for years and
people were furious at you people lost
their minds yeah and I made it very
specific it was like this is actually
you know Venkatesh from Mumbai who
collaborates with person a and B and
Manila who does mostly copy editing and
we've actually been crafting this at the
behest of Tim Ferriss to prove a point
which is you can outsource anything with
the right set of instructions if you vet
the right people and people lost their
minds it was it was wild also to see the
response because I put it out I happened
to be I think I was in London at the
time and I used that time difference as
a way to be somewhat sneaky and
published it the day before April first
in the US which made it extra confusing
very deliberately and I went to sleep
not thinking much of it just having a
chuckle after a glass or two of wine and
woke up to just mayhem I mean its arms
and legs in the streets of the Internet
it was just complete mayhem and high it
was it was also funny this is gonna be
very politically incorrect but how
I buy fur kated a lot of the responses
were seemingly by gender like the men
were like you [ __ ] dick and then a
handful on both sides were like okay
that's pretty funny and then the women
were like how could I ever trust you
again I could never trust you again but
it was a mess
it created a real mess now I didn't
bring this up but it's in my notes so
you are not a junior varsity April
Fool's joke person yourself so can you
talk about I'll start us off actually
let me let me let me just read this
so you wrote okay dot dot dot I said it
would never happen but now in April two
thousand eighteen after so many blog
posts after 18 books dozens of projects
and a bunch of ebooks and videos and
podcasts I'm now completely out of ideas
big ideas small ideas any idea is all
gone used up I have none left what
happened when you publish that so here's
this goes back to the empathy thing I
got a lot of email that at first really
annoyed me and what the email said was
you're right you're out of ideas I've
been out of ideas for a long time too I
feel terrible for you here are some tips
I have on how you can find the ideas
again don't feel too badly and what I
realized was they weren't writing the
note to me they were writing the note to
themselves and they weren't angry but
there was a lot of pathos involved in it
because they still believed in writer's
block they still believed in this myth
that they were out of ideas and they
were getting a lot of schadenfreude and
pleasure out of the fact that I also had
their affliction now because I was the
arrogant guy who said it could never
happen and it happened to me and they
were sort of gloating about it and
here's the thing writer's block is a
myth what people get stuck on is not
that they're out of ideas
it's that they think they're out of good
ideas that everyone has bad ideas and my
only argument is
if you put enough bad ideas into the
world sooner or later your brain will
wake up and good ideas will come and
that the bad boss problem is your bad
boss won't let you ship anything because
he or she is insisting on perfect and I
have been 7400 blog posts and I've done
four perfect ones
so you just got to keep making the work
with generosity because then your lizard
brain will give up on censoring you
because it realizes you're not going to
give up and at that point I'll just say
well we might as well make it better and
that volume comes from putting one foot
after the other as you have done 7400
blog posts that is just incredible and I
took some notes on later discussion of
this April Fool's joke they put out and
just to underscore something I already
said about writer's block and feel free
to correct me if this is incorrect but
roughly quote no one gets plumbers block
they simply do plumbing creativity is
work it's not the muse or lightning or
the result of burning incense I write
daily because I'm a professional and
this is what I do and I think it's a
it's a it's a strong it seems to me to
be a strong commitment and then holding
yourself to that commitment whether it's
doing the work daily whether it's having
the boundaries that you have whether
it's having deadlines that you do not
miss because you decide that that's
going to be a defining characteristic of
you and your life because you don't want
to be many other things and to force
yourself as a square peg into a round
hole as many people do attempt for their
entire lives very impressive and I think
a very important point that the
authenticity of maybe suffering from the
the changing winds of how you feel a
minute to minute can be override 'add in
many respects by viewing yourself as a
professional even if you're just getting
started deciding that that you are going
to do the
work and even through dozens of bad
ideas or not eat not even through have
faith that through coming up with many
ideas you will eventually have to come
up with a few good ones yeah I think
that's brilliant and if I'm gonna you
know to quote Roz and ER and the but
verses and you can say to yourself I'm a
writer but no one's reading my work I'm
an artist but no one's buying my
paintings and the but becomes the
essence of your day or you can say I get
to write and no one is buying my
painting and no one is buying my work
yet I get to paint and no one is buying
my paintings yet the and is true you got
both things are true so what are you
gonna do about it well one thing you can
do about it is stop or the other thing
you can do about it is get better and
you don't get better and I spent a bunch
of pages in the book talking about what
better means you don't get better by
getting rid of typographical errors they
don't get better by being more realistic
in your painting you get better by
serving the needs and wants and desires
and dreams of the smallest viable
audience you sought to serve and if
you're not serving them by offering them
a way forward with status with tension
with where they want to go then it's no
wonder there's no line out the door but
if you can turn that and into now I see
them and I can give them what they want
then your work is going to get seen well
I think this is a very complete arc of a
conversation Seth and remember someone
told me once I can't remember who it was
but it was someone said the what
distinguishes the amateur from the
professional this was in the context of
writing short stories and it wasn't only
what to write about it was when to end
it so I want to start to wrap up with no
particular emergency rush because I
think we've really covered
more than I could have hoped for in a
very cohesive way are there any other
and certainly I'll mention a few places
where people can find you and we can
mention many more things but are there
any other particular resources or
recommendations that you would have
requests of people listening for things
they should do any any parting comments
or or last comments for this
conversation that come to mind well I
have to say that once you're on my
agenda and my calendar I spent a lot of
hours thinking about making sure we get
the most out of these conversations
because you dig so deep and it's really
a privilege to do it so I have a couple
completely irrelevant slightly related
probably on topic things I would point
people to so here we go
check out what's happening in the EU
about the balkanization of copyright and
how a land grab is happening that could
very well break the internet Cory
Doctorow is written brilliantly about
this I thought it would be worth
highlighting the fact that five people
who I know have written books about
their nonprofit work or close to
nonprofit work that matter didn't had an
impact on me I'll lead him to you quick
Scott Harrison's new book is called
thirst and it's the autobiography of
charity water cat Hoku you know and her
book a second chance was magnificent
a walk in their shoes by a leader named
Jim Zell Kowski was about how Jim from a
job at GE built an institution that's in
countries around the world changing the
lives of underprivileged kids the blue
sweater by my friend Jacqueline
Novogratz about her journey in now a
couple hundred million dollars at acumen
fund and Shaun asked Anozie who is not
running a non-profit he's runs a
Chocolate Company and his book
meaningful work I find it all five of
these peak books fit together and when
you read them you can apply 90% of what
they're talking about to building your
for-profit enterprise because it's all
the same its value who
you're creating value for and while
you're creating that value I love it
I can I can second a number of those
books and where would you suggest people
learn more about you more about the new
book where would you suggest they go
well all the blog posts are at Seth's
blog and if you go to Seth's top blog
slash t IM not named after Tim Ferriss
you will find this is marketing which is
where I put a couple videos about the
new book I did not know it's good for
Tim when I wrote the book and the alt
MBA has some sessions signing up now for
January it's at alt nba.com and between
all that that is enough to keep people
busy for a while
wonderful and people can find the
Twitter repost of your blog if they want
to keep up with the blog post at at this
is Seth's blog Seth it's always such a
pleasure and I always learned so much
and have taken so many notes for myself
I really appreciate you taking the time
thanks boss
it was fun I'll see you next time to be
continued and to everybody listening
thank you for listening and you can find
show notes links to everything including
sus new book and everything that we've
discussed in the show notes as per usual
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
and until next time keep experimenting
stay safe and have fun hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed this episode
is brought to you exclusively by
LinkedIn marketing solutions the go-to
tool for VP marketers and advertisers
who want to drive brand awareness
generate leads will build long-term
relationships that result in real
business impact could be all of the
above I've had Reid Hoffman the
co-founder of LinkedIn on his podcast a
number of times often called the Oracle
of Silicon Valley for many different
reasons and he among other people and
friends of mine have made me more and
more interested in LinkedIn as a
platform as an ecosystem in the last few
years and it's it's very nuanced it's
very subtle but can be used in some very
powerful ways with a community of more
than five hundred and seventy five
million professionals LinkedIn is
gigantic but it can be hyper specific
you have access to a very diverse group
of people all searching for things they
need to grow professionally that is
explicitly the purpose of LinkedIn and
four out of five users on LinkedIn are
decision-makers at their companies so
you can build relationships that really
matter that can drive your business
objectives forward but can also have a
high LTV lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job federal
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective
so why spray-and-pray with your
marketing dollars when you can be
surgical it just makes sense to redeem a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit and launch
your first campaign go to linkedin.com
forward slash TFS that stands
Tim Ferriss show so that is linkedin.com
potage TFS check it out that's where you
can go to get your free $100 ad credit
LinkedIn com forward slash TFS terms and
conditions apply
[Applause]